[Music]
for many of us one of the most upsetting
moments of adulthood was learning that
the five-second rule doesn't exactly
hold up five-second rule
to get to the bottom of other widely
believed food rules and find out what's
true and what's bogus according to the
agency that regulates food safety we
reached out to Peter Cassell a
spokesperson for the FDA to ease your
eating worries here are eight food
safety questions you've likely had at
one point in your life rule number one
it's unsafe to drink milk past its
sell-by date even if it's just a day or
two not necessarily as cassell explains
drinking milk a day or two after the
milk sell-by date may not be a safety
issue but may be more of a taste issue
that said drinking milk any amount of
time past it's expiration date does
increase the risk of developing
foodborne illness from bacteria that
might have grown says Cassell but unless
you're part of a population that should
play it extra safe
elderly people pregnant women and young
children would fall into that category
and if your milk is within a few days of
its sell-by date then you're probably
good to go
just give it a whiff before you drink it
rule number two you shouldn't drink from
a cup of water that has been left
sitting out overnight probably false
your water might taste a little funny if
it's been sitting on your bedside table
overnight but water from a clean glass
is still perfectly fine to drink after
all Cassell says water itself has no
ingredients that would make it go bad
however sipping does transmit
microorganisms from your mouth to the
cup it's a good idea to swap out your
dirty glass for a clean one each day
rule number three white discoloration on
a chocolate bar means the chocolate has
gone bad
false if you were thinking of throwing
out that discolored bar of chocolate you
just unwrapped think again a white film
on the surface of your chocolate might
look alarming but it's most likely just
a fat bloom this occurs when cocoa
butter fats separate from Coco says
Cassell although considered a defect
it's safe to eat rule number four butter
should be stored in the fridge not at
room temperature in a butter dish true
if your household is in the habit of
leaving a butter dish out in room
temperature maybe you should rethink the
practice according to Cassell doing so
puts butter at risk of increased rates
of oxidative rancidity which leads to
the more rapid development of an unusual
or unpleasant flavor on the other hand
refrigeration both preserves the shelf
life of the butter and reduces the
growth rates of spoilage microbes which
might be present so refrigerate your
butter and if you want warm spreadable
butter try using a serrated warming
butter knife rule number five fruits and
vegetables should be washed before
eating this is true all fresh produce
can be contaminated in many ways animals
dangerous substances such as pesticides
and workers can all contribute to
contamination according to one
Environmental Working Group analysis the
USDA has found that nearly 70% of
conventionally grown produce samples
tested positive for pesticide residues
so unless your fresh produce and fruit
is marked pre-washed for ready-to-eat be
sure to give it a good wash before
prepping or eating it especially if it's
one of the Dirty Dozen strawberries in a
tale nectarine apple grapes peaches
cherries pears tomatoes celery potatoes
and hot peppers rule number six raw eggs
will make you sick
since you can't tell from the outer
shell or inside of the egg if it's
contaminated always refrigerate eggs and
cook them until the yolk is firm raw
eggs have a chance of being contaminated
with harmful bacteria such as salmonella
but since bacteria are microscopic you
won't be able to just read the bad eggs
out the best practice is to refrigerate
handle
cook eggs properly says Cassell cook
eggs until both the yolk and white are
firm and cook any egg dishes until they
are at an internal temperature of 160
degrees Fahrenheit or hotter rule number
seven
you shouldn't double-dip true double
dipping can spread bacteria and is
especially sketchy because a person
doesn't have to be visibly sick or sick
at all to pass on germs it's best to put
dip on your own plate so that you can
enjoy it without spreading any germs to
others says Cassell if you know that you
are ill it may be a good idea stay away
from communal snacks or foods altogether
rule number eight if you bring a
homemade salad to work you should
refrigerate it immediately keeping it at
room temperature could make it go bad by
lunchtime true it all comes down to what
kinds of ingredients you pack in your
salad but spoiler alert they're most
likely perishable and should be
refrigerated as soon as possible
lettuce dairy based dressing cheeses and
other produce in your salad should be
stored properly at temperature of 40
degrees Fahrenheit or below and most
proteins such as meat poultry eggs and
seafood should all be refrigerated
within two hours of cooking or
purchasing or within one hour if the
temperature outside is above 90 degrees
Fahrenheit Seska self so basically
unless you're planning on a 10 a.m.
lunch you should store your salad in an
insulated lunch bag with a pack of ice
or just stick your Tupperware in the
office fridge so now that you know these
rules you can consume with a little
peace of mind enjoy your food
[Music]
you
[Music]